*Felix Crying*
Cardboard Felix: What's the matter PewDiePie?
Felix: Well, ever since you lost your legs..
I have no one to react with..
(Unknown): What about me?
I have a cringe challenge for  you, PewDiePie. Pewds: Who said that?
Felix: Where are you? !
(unknown): I love you.
Kiss these plastic lips
(Overlapping) Pewds: Show Yourself!
(Unkown Source): boy
(Distorted sound)
Garble..
(Getting warm in this vid)
(oooooOOOOOOOOOOOhhHhhhhHHHHHH)
(#donttellmarzia)
How did you know my favorite thing, these things are practically free views!
Hey you wanna hit that,
You wanna hit that vape, Garble?
(Dope music)
Hell yeah.
I'm smokin' a pipe!
Here you go, let me hit you up.
(Felix making himself laugh)
"TV Reporter Accidentally Ruins Martial Art..-
..'s Master Demo."
Martial Artist: I'm gonna break that concrete slab with that glass without breaking the glass.
*Felix imitating him* Without breakin' the glass!
TV Reporter: You ready? Martial Artist: I'm ready. Let's go.
Felix: Oh I'm excited for this, this is gonna be good.
Come on.. How is he gonna do that?
How?? That's dangerous! Don't do it!!
Garble!
(Sound of concrete breaking)
Pewds: Woah.. Reporter: That's incredible!
Reporter: To be honest, I actually felt these bricks, these are real bricks.
I mean there's no- Martial Artist: Don't! (He warned him enough...)
Reporter: Woah woahh!
Waahhh! (trying so hard to hide his mistake)
Reporter: Check it out, baby.
Reporter: Guns. Martial Artist: GUNS!
Martial Artist: How the hell did you do that?? (Reporter laughing) (Martial Artist trying to keep up with the Reporter's shit)
(Felix cringing noises)
(In The End by Linkin Park plays)
Reporter: That was- Good job, good job..
Pewds: OHHH THE HANDSHAKE-
(Cringing noises)
(Felix dying of cringeyness)
THE HANDSHAKE..
Give me a replay of that shit!
What the fuck?
*In the end by Linkin Park playing*
*Groans* OHHHHHHHH
It hurts! This is why I love you, Gubble (Gubble?) because you don't have any fucking hands.
There's no way we can handshake!
Gubble: On to the next cringe video
"Pharrell Stops Functioning For 20 Seconds...
...and it's awkward.."
Neil deGrasse Tyson: The frequencies that are generated within atoms are far more accurate
than anything earth, and the sun and the moon have ever dreamed of doing.
And that- so now we use the atomic clock
And we can- and you want to have time and space
Pharrell interrupts: Oh, the atomic clock is really based on, like atoms?
Neil deGrasse: Oh yea! so now you bring the clock in to space
(Pharrell is "amazed")
Neil deGrasse Tyson: And you don't-
Neil deGrasse Tyson: you- you no longer have to- yeah exactly (laughs)
WOAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
Felix:Oh.
Neil deGrasse: It's actually based on electrons (Pharrell is still going WOAHHHHHHH)
Pewds:He keeps going huh?
Neil DeGrasse Tyson: To be precise Pharrell:WOAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
Pewds:Pharrell stop!
Neil: I don't know what frequency that is...
Pewds:JUST FUCKING STOP!
Dude in the video: It's Mind Blown Remix Pewds: No!
Neil: Is that what that is? (laughs)
(Pharrell is mindblown) Pewds: What The F*CK WAS THAT?
*Groans*
WHAT THE SHIT
(Pharrell Settting the world record for the longest WOAH.
Well...
We managed to fi- find someone more unfunny than me; How 'bout that?
Pharrell
Pharrell, everyone
Maybe he should just stick to his music
*gets out of topic* "Woman Takes Creep Shot of Guy's Junk."
(why is the girl doing a face dance?)
Oh. Look at her, she looks so guilty!
Oh fuck yeah!
oh...
Look at her, she looks so guilty!
This is the least casual person I've ever seen!
*Felix is freaking out* SHE MADE EYE CONTACT WITH THE CAMERA
OOOHHHH
OH
*Stutters*
*Felix making an impression of the girl* Phones! How do they work??
Let me see that shit again.
That was beautiful.
(Comedy show credits)
How are you doing now- You look so cute in this shot :3
Isn't this a great shot?
*Garble attacking Felix*
hey
Garble!
gARBLE
GARBLE
"Bill Clinton Denied a Kiss From Hillary."
*Hillary leans to Bill
*Leans away and leans to Obama
*Gives Obama a kiss :* *
*Felix is amused*
*Weird noises*
WHAT
THE
FUCK
Well, you know what they say...
Once you go....
President....
*Stutters*
You come back....
Alright moving on. (FINISH YOUR GODDAMN SENTENCE)
*More comedy credits...*
"Code Babes"
Camille (from the video):Hey this is Camille for CodeBabes.com
Want to learn the code?
Are you having trouble paying attention?
Welcome to your solution.
All the other sites offer same shit. (At an advertisement, really?
We take [inaudible] to the next level
Offering real positive feed back
like Pavlov's dog on crack (SO MUCH DOOOGGGEEE)
Felix: She said shit.....
This must be legit.
Camille: You watch a lesson...
Absorb the info
pass the quiz
Felix interrupts: And then you jerk off!
Cam: Your instructor will remove one piece of clothing (HUWAT)
(Hallelujah for Felix)
Felix: oh my fucking God thATS GENIUS
Cam: So join some ridiculously hot code babes and start your web development career today.
*Felix actually doing so*
Felix: I don't even care about coding!
A-Alright- I get to select which one!
Do I wanna learn...
(Android Virgin.....)
The Android Virgin...
yeah- I'll go with the Android Virgin; I think
Thank you very much :)
*Skips the vid to find the girl naked*
*Boring shit...*
When the fuck is she taking her clothes off?
Felix: It's always great to learn stuff from people who don't know what the fuck they're talking about
Activity is just how Android refers to-
*Insert sarcasm* That really- That really inspires me to learn because there's really passion behind the words
Woman: I love sushi.
Man: I love Japan; period.
[Inaudible]
oh my God I've seen this one, I've seen this one a very long time ago!
GURUGOME
Felix: GURUGAME *laughs*
YEHEHESSS
I forgot about that meme it was so fucking good!
GURUGAME
Other dude: I love anime!
Oh my God....
Is this real?I never watched beyond this part!
*Imitates other dude* I love anime!
OD: I love anime!
OG: And manga!
OOD: AND GAMING!
Felix: AND GAMING
Onision: This is my vegitarian BOOODDEEEEHH
aND GAMINg
vEGAN BODY
*Clusterfuck of voices*
Felix: I would love to be that person
I would LOVE to be that person <3
So much.
People are just randomly talking about the stuff they like
*Imitating* Oh man, this food is so good!
And just randomly pop in with a fucking thing in your hand
AND GAMIIING
And gaming!
Anime!
OG: and manga!
I love this video <3
That's a great fucken video.
A really good video.
*Moves on to the next topic* "Sonic Heroes Happy Meal Ad."
It's in Pakistan.
*Distorted Captions incoming*
i"ll cHECKMYHAPPYMEAL
Tayls SUKER
Sanic SKETBORD
*Laughs*
No...
Poor Sonic- can you stop
fucking Sonic?
He's been fucked enough! (He's not a virgin anymore??)
Stop!
sANiC SKETBORD
*Imitates* Sonic Sketbord!
(More sanic sketbord)
Shedow BASKETBOL
*Imitates last line*
Knukels BAYSBAWL
*groans*
*wat*
Garble: Cringe, PewDiePie.
You will cringe, PewDiePie
YOU WILL CRINGE PEWDIEPIE!
Watch this last video!
"Mine-con 2016." (Get ready guys this is some veeerrryyy bad shit.)
Host: Oh, hello!
It has to be an ocelot, right?
*Girl shakes her head*
[Inaudible] See your tail?
Host: Oh okay.
She's actually my favorite game  character ever; It's tails (Here it comes...)
Girl: .....I'm STAMPY.
(RIP Felix, Cause of death: Too much cringe)
*ULTIMATE CRINGE GROAN
HAHAHAH
o-ho.. Oh no
It was Stampy, you dumb bitch
Oh no.